so what's it like having new misfit kids
on the block and what's it like being
the guy who's returning not enjoying it
Galia both incredibly racist nice
brilliant my it's absolutely wonderful
it's lovely to be to be back dear win
definitely and I said it's wonderful to
come but yes it's wonderful to come back
and it's wonderful to spend this well
there's time with these dicks thanks for
that man
no worries yeah alright do you think of
him before you actually got on set just
from having seen him on the show didn't
like the look at him shifty dodgy he
wears under his pockets a lot for stuff
and that okay always fidgeting misreads
coins I've got to try and find change
you can't see it on camera doesn't have
been person he's always got a really
thin film snot on the top I've got
problems ever only the size of a sinus
problems
he'll sweat loads of you to zoom in here
right now as you can see it now on the
top of his own at least looks very
lightweight I've not been very well so
I'm wearing a couple of lazier at
comic-con I'm wearing one too that's
three four five and that's me six layer
as if that's gonna prevent pattern on
the biscuits getting rid of flu it's
getting rid of me me mum flu we haven't
quite got the pan to overcome the flu
yet but which one of you actually got
the short straw when the superpowers
were handed out in the show oh yeah yeah
you don't want yeah you don't know what
my power is in the end it's you're so
sexy honest not all right it is a bottom
of Howard almonds Brin barrel racer cost
yeah it's just a million okay no I'm
people are gonna see me blah oh yeah
you're a misfits then after week it's
gonna be I genuinely don't worry Barry
where's mine mine is hair millions it's
pretty cool yes yours was really
carefully news crap where is his curl
but he's in role in Fame with the show
he's crap at it yeah his arms brilliant
with mine hahaha what a helmet then that
you don't even get Saddam the orange
jumpsuit no I don't you know he's
constantly why didn't talk about it
being picked on then initially do you
know what I initially I thought oh
that's really bike it's kind of
quintessentially but then I realize how
disgusting these two looked in orange
jumps just accentuates all of the kind
of camel toes prophecy camel toes got
[ __ ] straight down Callister that's
alright it's a bit cool now you can
proper seat Frank and beans through it
I'm not joking I'm not kidding talking
of which GT guys got a bit of a bromance
going on having you tell us me more yeah
we do have a bromance don't where you
have you do you guys come from because I
thought that small food book racist is
Alton oh it's quite it to get quite
emotional haha really a retire it is
good to get quite emotional I think
reading and finding yeah there is a bit
of it there's a we have a bit of a
fallout at one point we allowed to talk
about that fall out we do have a lover's
TIFF where he kicks me out and I have
where do I live up that wanted just shot
it you sleep on the street for a while I
do sleep on the street I have sex with a
[ __ ] with a quite a beautiful [ __ ]
Gayle but they're kind of unite in just
taking this on me like they see the
Bauman's because it just I hate them I
like a million misfits my character
hates them cleared so it that that's
kind of there so the bullying is
necessary yeah they're just unite
they're they're bigger but then whenever
I'm in the mix it suddenly two verse one
reading I can see there might be a quite
an interesting atmosphere on the
sector's from talking to you guys now
tell us a little bit about it and who
gets up to the pranks he's the biggest
prank place yes a lot similar rig
simulated rapes disgusting he pulls up
your pants and Pat's you on the back
there's a kissing on the record good
good luck rests on me after it oh it's
just we were saying like in the in the
what to call the press think that if
you've got an insecurity it's everyone
else's responsibility to just completely
gone I literally in like a week
George is declared everyone that I had
massive Viking head is it yes look it's
I'm saying to his head look at the tiny
what would pay I'd complain I always
thought that's all I read to incise old
her
try and attach a bit of attention away
from the port now he's got this on his
faces don't shut up he's gone for that
just not available norms guys in real
life what superpower would you most like
to have real life I got trouble places
at X and them tell them tell them what
it right I got asked this question the
other day and I said I'd go back in time
and I'd stop one Direction's parents my
buying sex one in one direction that
just does Lords are shagging Harry
Styles Harry Styles
stop doing it stop shagging are you
gonna cap okay he'll get solos Harry
Styles is penis close it close it in on
it lose it once I just get really close
do that money now that's the kind of
advice that Rudy couldn't give Harry
stars isn't it ruining it
I'd like to go I'd love your power to go
out with Harry Styles unbeknown because
clearly I'm missing out on something
each just shagging everyone he's just
going around throwing it around lobbing
it all over the place are boxes of and
Alice didn't she's a liberal woman she's
very liberal reaching me friends of your
characters in real life and would you
really like a second year what would you
do if you did have a second year no I
would hate him in on him yeah I do I
hate the parrot they'd be buried it's
just a ginger terrible human beings is
all these stains when we're all together
and they're better than a bit cocktail
no it goes right you know what
let's just do this and then go shut up
let's just do this we're all of Libya
we're never all ten but we were sort of
beside my chippy to go back brilliant
let's do one except when I fires like
this yeah guys yeah well we're bout a
night we genuinely have a friggin
brilliance I everyone says this like you
know we all we all get on we all have a
great set we have a great friggin
hilarious very stressful and fall out a
lot ball you do end up you rock up now
and again after about three months when
it starts off you can if it's all about
the film and stuff but I for about three
months you literally rock up to dick
about what you made and someone round
someone eventually stressed out the
headset on comes over we have a frigate
words on yeah come on yeah that probably
had mullets come on come on laughing in
this one huh which are the episodes you
most
forward to saying and why six is just a
massive episode it's a much so much
happens in episode so it's kind of like
the holidays do yeah yeah I put my
weight
mmm oh yeah we all in the rumble another
band will party in episode 6 this is yes
that's right that's also understand we
giant-killer up there's a giant killer
rabbit shows up when we all have to kind
of make a six-foot killer up with a golf
club the block who played the rabbit and
my heart was cold Jack Jack Robin yes
absolute losses now maybe it won't be
nice I was going to go Ambika yeah yeah
it's cold as handsome as hell and come
on you never saw it you never sorry I
could leave totally handsome it was I
put it oh he is you could salute and cry
at the same time make you feel better
about a little having a jumpsuit knowing
that this is really good-looking guy but
he's under a rabbit soon yags every time
we saw him he was just covered in sweat
and retching retching films I made it
feels great what we did eventually had
terrible gingivitis and it's brave
inside that thing the whole day is over
he's in the corner of his mouth as well
and grabs crabs on his face on the moon
his eyebrows they stayed you Felix
Besson and Gemma see neither them well
y'all about you've said your cattle you
take one look it's like looking at a
bloody bin bag full of cottage cheese
I'll say this I'll say this about the
[ __ ] John suit is he's fitted this is
very his has been tailor fitting and in
the early photographs you can properly
see you can really save all the
obviously the most revealing things with
every wheel it went round Mothercare
trying to find it or anything I just did
it's not a tomato no stitch that one in
stitch that in front of orange hankies
and just turn him in it does action
Manwaring
genuinely does have whitey balls [ __ ]
look why levels banging into each other
you know sorry
that was kind of before thanks for
having us
you